on nous bernadette lafont vous êtes
resté la nouvelle vague malicieuse un
peu teinté de provincialisme animaux un
humour de tout l'être pour ne trouve
qu'au sud de la loire en général est-ce
que vous vous sentez languedocienne
encore ah oui oui surtout en arrivant
ici ou vraiment avait vraiment une ville
du midi
sans schéma oui absolument
beaucoup de beaux films ont été tournés
dans notre région les mistons depuis nos
débuts l'émission de truffaut dont le
premier
vraiment en tournée à lille donc c'était
complètement chez moi et puis j'ai
tourné dans les pyrénées orientales avec
doniol valcroze l'eau à la bouche et il
y avait le beau serge aussi en blu ray
ce n'est pas tellement loin
c'est un peu l'occitanie
donc cette nouvelle vague était teintée
de meridionalis mme si oui finalement
c'est à dire que c'était moi qui faisant
partie de la nouvelle vague à porte et
m'a apporté le midi c'est le grand ce
parfum de niche
et toulouse à ce que vous connaissiez
non pas du tout mon père en avait
beaucoup parlé parce qu'il a fait des
études de pharmacie
alors c'était vraiment ravi la gare d
attribution
et pour moi toulouse était
vous allez vous sentir chez vous j'ai
pas vu
vient alors il y a eu la nouvelle vague
puis après ça a été un peu le creux de
la vague wii est maintenant à nouveau
truffaut oui parce que je ne serai pas
votre porte chance votre catalyseur je
me demande oui ça quand il m'a proposé
de tourner le film avec le sujet et le
rôle formidable qui me proposait
effectivement j'ai pensé que c'était
pour moi pratiquement ma deuxième chance
et vos projets maintenant bernadette
lafont et bien mes projets maintenant
c'est tourner à nouveau avec un jeune
réalisateur qui a été la vedette des
films de jean luc godard qui rappelle la
sauce abu dont j'ai tournée le premier
long métrage l'année dernière les gants
blancs du diable et nous allons tourner
son deuxième film son deuxième long
métrage avec jean seberg
et c'est l'histoire de deux chanteuses
danseuse dans une boîte comme ça à
pigalle encore la nouvelle vague
oui oui et toujours ces gens pour dire
[Musique]